[Aplausos]
cuando es
con la frase de estudio muchas gracias
los periodistas
a
las noticias de exclusión confianza
sport y una cierta relevancia
pero pensar cuántos estudios científicos
se publican
actualmente se dominan más de 6 millones
de excluidos científicos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
toda esa información es relevante
para
el sistema
mándanos un poco cuál es un problema que
podría haber
al negar información y para ello quiero
empezar por recordar cómo funciona
como todos sabéis el primero sentido
consiste en la observación de más
intentamos dar una respuesta lógica para
eso planteamos hipótesis qué es
y ahora
qué
las conclusiones de nuestros éxitos en
la
materia
con lo cual no se pelean mucho para el
avance de baños por tanto es importante
esto hay un paso más allá y que
comuniquemos los pacientes porque la
ciencia pero se cuenta realmente
y esto te ha pasado de forma muy
relevante
una famosa frase del himno que dijo que
fue gracias a que estaba a unos de final
si quieren eso bueno pues quiere decir
que el conocimiento avanza gracias a los
avances
científicos que han llegado a otros
conocimientos
y por esas
sin duda uno debe pensar
si efectivamente podemos ir avanzando de
la comunicación al principio la relación
científica existía una comunicación
directa entre los científicos
no se trae cometiendo
compartido
algo así
a rendir
la universidad
y lo hacemos como
hola y las cartas que se enviaban de los
cuales tenéis algunos ejemplos
tenéis
por un lado caso
de la comunicación de baja
y por otro el que recibía dinero por eso
las primeras autoridades específicas
auxiliar a la creación de lo que
conocemos como revistas científicas
y esta revista significa que
estas técnicas permiten la diseminación
de la información
que es un
científico es un trabajo teórico como el
disco que contribuye al avance del
conocimiento como generamos esos apoyos
los peritos lo que hacemos es
es mejor
hay que hacerse preguntas al igual
es
una
de nuestras áreas no sólo para que los
demás los componentes sino para que si
los escribimos minuciosamente los demás
pueden reeditar en sus laboratorios con
lo cual
esto
cuando tenemos los conocidos
las técnicas tienen cinco días para
decidir si nuestros trabajos son
importantes son los suficientes
e interesantes y si cavani suárez ha
reconocido
si nosotros trabajamos en alguna de
estas 2
[Música]
y
qué hacemos cuando recibimos él
bueno pues la lengua
que tenemos y lo que hacemos
de acuerdo sigue previsor considera que
nuestro trabajo puede ser interesante
para supervisar el trato que haces
enviarlo a
que sobre esos revisores pues esos
revisores son otros científicos
nuestra muy próxima de conocimiento y
quiero viajen es estudiar minuciosamente
nuestro trabajo de forma que intentan
hacer un informe
de la importancia
sufriendo posible i
mira
si el lector cuando recibe esa
información de los televisiones
pues el trabajo pasará a ser tu vida
esta publicación
inicialmente lleva unos costes de
producción de calibración de impresión
de distribución de las revistas
y nos podemos preguntar bien para esos
gastos bueno pues aunque sea
sorprendente esos rastros los pagamos
los autores
es así nosotros en lugar
bien las regulares y por qué no hacéis
porque es
bueno que lo hacemos porque todo existe
y agua pivote sobre las complicaciones
científicas
para
[Música]
más experimentos necesita publicar
resultados para que las agencias
evaluadoras
reconsidere nuestro trabajo
ubicar más amigos y así él
[Música]
no solamente
los publicamos por elegancia
estaba lloviendo antes sino también por
un interés de un hombre entre comillas
por qué no implica también en muchos
casos nuestra canción vamos a llevar por
el personal
a una manera que se ha hecho muy popular
los científicos tienen
que viene a decir aguas públicas o
perdés
este todo este entramado sufrió un
impacto importante de osario
podéis imaginar
aparición de internet y lo pensaba mucha
gente de que quizá la revista era
necesario puesto que ella podríamos
tener nuestras publicaciones críticas en
internet nos basamos en el papel
físicamente y eso llevó a plantearnos
preguntas como la diferencia
por mes en el cual se planteaba si
podían ser las editoriales científicas
la primera víctima de indiana
como los humanos somos muy buenos
haciendo siempre que nos perdimos el
futuro porque ahora
perspectiva
sino que han incrementado
significativamente sus alcances
era bailar el negocio que mueve esta
industria superó 105 millones de dólares
al bar
es una cifra real similar
por siempre que mueva tanto dinero como
va para que esté como se genera tanto
pues sí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
incluso esa empresa
muchísimo y el 12 3%
cuando mueve la industria
automovilística de su mano en el equipo
sangre
y la madera
y
las tecnologías
el presente decidido de las editoriales
científicas
pues si está abundando y 40 mujeres
como podéis ser eso
bien vamos a plantearnos un poco cómo
funciona todo
vamos a ver
[Música]
la población de ese espectro que acabo
de mencionar antes sin mencionarlo
ellos vamos a poder dentro como de ese
supermercado mente
y es en supermercados de patatas porque
se la sombra del mundo
[Música]
no sólo por las patatas
somos los amores
pero vamos a tocar ahí
en el proceso derivado
hasta los supermercados
constituyen transportistas de trabajos
han imaginado que esos transportistas
tampoco cobrarán los trabajos
lucían en unos combustibles
de sus mínimos de su propio bolsillo y
se pagan en un solo supo para la
seguridad
pues esos son los revisores que hacen
nada total no reenviar
con lo cual al final en el supermercado
donde las paradas y el público se las
compra en la analogía a las habilidades
indígenas también es así que el lector
las vistas obras por acceder a esa
información
de acuerdo con lo cual es un negocio
real
cómo es posible cómo es posible que
según esto funcione sin pensar que las
agencias de financiación los financian a
los investigadores para pagarnos
abrir nuestras revistas pero luego
tienen que pagarles a las autoridades
para que otros científicos nuestra
propia institución puedan las cometas
bueno
bueno pues todo el sistema parecía
memorable aparecieron recientemente a
una
y en el cual el acceso
para los lectores
[Música]
la información pero motores seguimos
ganando y además como podéis ver
los resultados aunque
[Música]
gracias
no esperamos
y además el inmediato crisis y la
aparición de la digitalización y de
editar de esto ha facilitado que hayan
aparecido nuevas tutoriales que compitan
con las clásicas y que tengan digamos
unos estándares científicos más gracias
y en algunos casos incluso para mujeres
porque esta es precisamente la famosa
vamos a casa
publicar en la diversidad que tenemos
los autores que complicaron por esto
[Música]
puntos editoriales que se domina
y simplemente pagando nos publicar
cualquier cosa lo que líneas queda mucho
mejor
para mí
porque sabemos que estas editoriales y
estas revistas
publicando alguien cosas para dar una
forma de todos
viendo últimamente
muchos
muchas indicaciones para enviar
[Música]
un correo electrónico
de una revista en la que si os fijáis ni
siquiera se sabe muy bien mi nombre
y esto
y yo sé nada básicamente
y lo preguntas en esa mina es de que hay
que pagar
de acuerdo con lo cual
la raíz más libre bueno no tienen por
favor
los investigadores japoneses en su libro
sin ninguna sin ningún
pero son
preocupantes bueno pues nosotros pero
tampoco demasiado al menos en uno de los
sentidos porque pues porque como veis
hay aproximadamente el 60% de estas
combinaciones no reciente como ninguna
por la general terminó pero nadie señor
esas rodillas bueno eso podía sentir
parte en otros dos días
pero no existe cuando se pueda comunicar
hace unos agujeros y para eso con ser
realidad
un investigador de la universidad de
north carolina
que explicó cómo está
[Música]
[Aplausos]
recibí un correo electrónico con buenos
acabados
vivimos de una belleza y decidió
comprobar si
realmente cualquier cosa
siento que podía ser muy grande
enseñar a los alumnos de tímida así
intentaba sintetizar
la
popular serie de televisión
latino total de errores incongruencias
los factores son y estiman igual
lenguaje los dos personajes principales
[Música]
trabajo directamente
o incluso podría de adaptar el teléfono
y llamar a la policía bien estoy
diciendo sintética metanfetamina
en el paquete
y él
y muchas gracias
y
publicar articulos violentos y estos
hijo de ser vendidos por tipo de ser
queridos porque aborda el camino de la
pseudociencia
y de los dos puede llevarnos a las
seguro
esto es realmente un peligro uno de los
peligros que tenemos en las
exportaciones limitadas
todavía un poco más
[Música]
números especiales que son los números
especiales
serían vistos
que pueden ampliar la labor de
reconocido
y convertirse en enemigo para los
números son los tres que haces en todo
pues es editor invitado es invitar a
unos exponeros respetuosos
con lo cual esto si os fijáis con amparo
de la pertinente publicación con lo cual
se está convirtiendo en un ordenador muy
finalizado como todas las estafas
piramidales con lo cual
[Música]
a
y podemos estar mirando
pública y porque publicar vemos suplicar
demasiado
pero realmente
vale
y con esto activamente ya dejamos que
tiene favor
y este por favor si alguna vez os
convertís en editores de álbum
una revista no militante muchas gracias
[Aplausos]